1.9 trillion dollar stimulus okay
fine where's this 1.9 trillion dollars
of stimulus
that they want to force to pass without
the approval by the way unemployment
right now you know what i'm unemployment
is right now
type up unemployment right now seven
percent what's seven percent
it's seven is that where it is right now
it's at seven percent okay
is seven percent the end of the world no
it's seven percent hey
we're at twelve percent i think when
when we were at twelve percent did we
send money out
yeah we did no when we were under under
other administration under
obama under uh did obama when
unemployment okay
maybe do this go put history of
unemployment rate go history of
unemployment rate
and here's where i want to go with this
history of unemployment rate go to
images
oh actually right there that site is a
good side more if you go back yeah click
on that site the balance unemployment
says 1929 go up
let's look at some stats here okay go to
2008
okay 2008 uh
when it was when it was 7.3 did obama
send us a stimulus
when it was 9.9 in 2009 did we get a
stimulus
when it was a 9.3 did we get stimulus
when we when it was eight
the doors four years send us stimulus
what is the unemployment right now 2021
right now so type in unemployment 2021
2021 unemployment unemployment rate i
gotta say it's somewhere around six
seven percent
currently i think the highest i think
the highest was gonna be the rate
yeah twelve percent and april okay six
point three percent six point three okay
you you're sending 1.9 trillion dollars
at 6.3
unemployment so here's what they want to
spend the money for hypothetically okay
so
yeah we think we need to do two trillion
dollars because america's slow to
recovery direct payments of 1400 to most
americans
what does most mean give me a specific
qualification bringing into total relief
to two thousand dollars including
december 600
payment increase the federal per week
unemployment benefit to 400
and extending it through the end of
september
seven months additional increasing the
federal minimum wage to 15
an hour extending the eviction and
foreclosure
moratoriums until the end of september
okay 350 billion dollars in state and
local government aid what's what's it
going to be
spent on i'm curious show it to me 170
billion dollars for k through 12
school and institution of higher
education 50 billion dollars towards
cova testing fine
20 billion dollars towards national
vaccine program and partnership with
states local and tribes
making a child tax credit fully
refundable for the year and increasing
the credit to three thousand dollars per
child
thirty six hundred dollars for a child
under the age of six the plan is the
first of two major spending
initiatives biden will seek in his first
few months of his presidency
according to senior biden officials
senior biden officials have been working
with the stimulus plans for weeks also
confirmed that the president
will support ten thousand dollars in
student debt so two trillion dollars
now we look at two trillion dollars and
what do we say come on man pat's not
really a big deal
okay oh it's a big deal i if i ask you
this question you already know the
answer to this question so you know
in the history of america how much money
have we
ever printed do you know the answer to
this question no okay
paul do you actually know the answer to
this question from day one
1776 till today how much money
have we printed how much money is in
circulation
from day one america till today from day
one
to today yes day one till today i would
say eight or nine trillion i was gonna
say
under 10 trillion dollars okay 6.1
trillion dollars okay
ever ever do you know how much of it was
in 2020
40 i think yeah two trillion dollars
was in 2020 in one year versus 240 years
for if you want to pull up that link
that i sent you
on this is from the board of governors
of the federal reserve okay
that is money stock m1 okay you go all
the way back
to now look look what happened in 2020
how much money was
look what happened in 2020 and the
amount of 41 of it was printed just
this year 2020. oh let's do another 2
trillion oh let's do another 2 trillion
oh let's do another 2 trillion
you can close that up what's the moral
of the story here
listen i mean hey you know
look what's what's happening to these
stocks they're going to the roof look
what's happening to
you know gold is not you know 70 000 per
kilo whatever the number is oh look at
what's going on with
you know all these other things that
baseball cards a michael jordan rookie
card a year ago you could buy one for
forty thousand dollars one just sold at
an auction for seven hundred thousand
dollars
whatever you can't over print the values
of those things are going up
land is going to go up you got uh what
do you call it a goal bitcoin and gold
oh look what happened with all bitcoin
you got baseball cards collectibles
these things are going up and we keep
printing money so if you keep printing
money what happens oh my gosh look at
the economy it's so great hyperion's
going up everybody's so happy
everybody's so good everybody's up there
look how great things are looking really
okay watch how bad it's gonna hit us all
of a sudden
watch how bad it's gonna hit us all of a
sudden this is a very very
important time to actually sit down with
your husband and your wife and
strategize what you want to do or even
yourself what you're going to do with
your strategy moving forward
money-wise this is not it like you had
another you know a couple trillion
dollars what is that two trillion
dollars come from
are we sitting on 50 trillion dollars of
cash no are we in debt a hundred and
something trillion dollars china oh yeah
we owe one billion
four hundred one billion forty billion
dollars
we owe 1.1 billion dollars they're just
spending money as if it's like keep
printing it it's okay
we can't afford to keep printing it so
here's my question for you okay because
clearly
by your tone you're not happy with all
the printing is that fair to say
it it would be an understatement okay
you're not happy with this would be an
understatement
you know obviously there's certain you
know um
republicans on certain side of the aisle
the ted cruz's of the world you know the
fiscal conservatives what have you that
obviously have the same philosophy as
you like what the hell are we doing with
all this printing i'm kind of there with
you as well
yeah so the other side of the coin you
have jerome powell
you have janet yellen obviously biden
people on the
by administration saying we need to add
more stimulus to the economy interest
rates are
literally rock bottom we can borrow our
way out of this
grow the gdp pay off some debt yeah
like it's no secret janet yellen jerome
powell
the bride administration they're
basically saying spend spend spend spent
spend
so my question is if they're the
foremost
thought leaders economically in this
country right she is the
uh treasury secretary she's the former
fed chairman
jerome powell now uh fed chair
do they know what they're talking about
do do they know what they're talking
about right
now there's a big difference between
knowing what you're talking about and
making a short-term decision versus a
long-term decision okay
this is not about of course these are
brilliant brilliant people powell is not
a dummy to go up there and says yeah
we're going to keep the interest rates
low until 2023.
there is knowing what you're doing you
know for the benefit of
the future generations of whoever there
is the other part guys we need a
band-aid just
we're bleeding just freaking you know
tie it up do it get something out there
you know ty
yeah the approach that being taken is
not about how smart these folks are let
me give you an idea for example
what industry took the biggest hit the
last 12 months airline travel
airline who else hotels hotels
restaurants
restaurants okay hospitality fine by the
way airlines to me a part of airlines
they need to go out of business
you ready you want them to fail this is
the shop not i want them to fail i want
the irresponsible ones to be bought by
responsible people
okay that's what i want to happen if
you're an irresponsible operator of a
company spending money left and right
you need to be bought by a responsible
operator because it's better for the
economy and the consumer for responsible
operator to run your company are there
uh who's the most responsible airline
operator
was it is it southwest delta is also one
of them spirit
is it spirit who's the
irresponsible is it united who's been
struggling the most united americans
listen we can pull up the numbers right
now kind of figure i'm just wondering
about that but go you were going
somewhere point
let the responsible people by the
irresponsible people
okay and let's change operation what did
one ceo do to southwest airlines
turned it around what did one great ceo
do to southwest airlines
think about it well why is why does
everybody hire somebody when on the
resume it says
i worked under jack welch for four years
why does everybody want to hire that
person
why is there a premium under i worked
under jack welch
why is there a premium i was an
assistant coach under bill belichick for
five years
why is there a premium for i was an
assistant coach under bill walsh under
phil jackson under
van gandy where is the premium why is
there such a big premium into coming
out of a sales program of xerox or ibm
xerox and ibm for decades were known as
the best
sales trend why is there a premium in
that because of what's being taught from
the top okay
okay so what's being taught from the top
you got these companies that are being
irresponsible i'm sorry you
that's that's your fault why'd you
overspend i'm gonna go back on your
track record and see how your spending
was no based on your spending
you just keep going into debt that's not
the response stock buybacks after the
way too much tax cuts number two what
industry my
concern my concern is on the bigger guys
they know exactly what they're doing
the biggest hit was taken by small
business owners running mom and pop shop
restaurants that's one
one shop one bar local yeah that's been
there for 15 years family passed down
for 40 years generation after generation
you want to help those guys out yeah we
ought to you know why because who shut
them down the government
the government is responsible for their
laws bail those guys out
i'm with you because you screwed them up
they didn't do anything wrong
i'm not telling you i don't want to go
to work i want to go to work you're
telling me i can't go to work well then
pay me
you understand that there's a
relationship here you create the laws
fine mr government you're creating the
laws
pay me support me because i got a wife
and kids and my savings is depleting
from 62 000 to fifty three thousand to
forty one i've been saving
sixty three thousand dollars may not be
a lot of money to
a rich person in wall street but sixty
three thousand dollars you know how many
people take a decade to save sixty three
thousand that's a lot of money yeah
sixty three k is a lot of money like you
know let's just spend some money
send the money here send the money there
you don't send the money to school we
want to send the money to education why
don't you send the money and build some
of these guys out
i understand education we don't we
rarely see it
how many times have you seen the
education program and your school's
getting better like you go
well not much has really changed where
did all this money go to where does all
this money go to so
my biggest challenge is accountability
you want to help out the restaurant
folks do so
i sat down one time and i talked to i
don't know zimmerman i don't know what
very political guy and you know what's
starting to happen today which this is
this is probably the most beautiful part
about what's going on right now in
america
my opinion one of the most beautiful
parts of what's going on in america
right now
california has a recall right now
they're trying to get new some out
okay and it's looking like they're gonna
get there by the way
do you know 30 of the people that voted
for newsome to be out
are democrats 30 of people
that are voting they are they are what's
the word where it's uh um
you're democrat it's an m ward they're
moderates they're moderates
right but they're democrats but they're
moderates right you know what is
happening today you know what's happened
in america today
politics is out the window it's pure
logic nowadays
shaman is saying i'm going to run for
governor shaman's not a republican he
wants to run against newsome what are
you running against news why you been
calling him
because now it's about all reasoning
throw
out the republican party throw out the
democratic party
now it's becoming about issues which is
beautiful i think it's a great thing
because it's so beautiful for so long
politics is big
emotional if you're replying hey trump
no way
now it's like hold on hold on yes but
but but the consequences the side
effects are now saying
listen man maybe 100 loyalty to my party
is kind of not working out
may hun maybe 100 loyalty for both sides
wake up call that you might want to say
that again by the way
maybe 100 of loyalty to your party is
not working out yep
both sides maybe now it's time we sit
there and we just
reason and process it oh my god that's
so powerful what you're saying right now
what we need to do because where we're
going today it's a beautiful thing
i agree because sakuan let's raise the
minimum wage hey let's stop
the oil and all this stuff oh let me
kind of pull that back i'm sorry i don't
know
why because even democrats don't like
what you're saying about that what do
you mean let's pull this out you're
going to cause all these people these
jobs
these are high-paying jobs these are
good jobs that you've got let's hold up
why are you changing your mind
what happened all of a sudden i thought
this was an executive order so we are
kind of being pushed by our own
community
it's like the father who goes home
here's what we're gonna do
and his son says that can i talk to you
yeah
i think you're wrong and i totally
disagree with the approach you're taking
right now
with your youngest son i think it's the
wrong approach and i'm not telling you
this in front because i know your dad
and i want to give you the respect but i
don't think you're taking the right
approach and i think you need to rethink
your decision on what you just did with
them
i think you're wrong and i know you're
upset with me i know you just but
i think i'm the only person i can say
something and who are you to talk to me
like this do you know what he did
tonight
he says dad i get it but i think you're
wrong and i hope you reconsider what
you're doing right now
it's the son that's calling out the
father right now and it's a beautiful
thing
and as long as a father sits there and
says maybe my son sees an angle that i
don't see
you have to consider that a little bit
this the feedback right we'll do things
here and i'll say mario what do you
think
pat i don't know about that i don't
think that's a good idea okay great hey
kai what do you think
yeah i don't i think we stick to this
okay cool it's now we're asking the what
do you think more instead of i know what
i'm doing and you
don't because i went to colombia i went
to
berkeley and you did not it's not how
life works today
people are getting called out from their
sides and i love it
i love it do you think we'll see another
progressive movement where there's
people
that are fighting for a cause regardless
of which party
do i think we will see first of all
these movements are not going away
just so you know what movements are you
talking about aoc is not going away
you know socialism movement's not going
to go away communism is not going to go
these movements are not going to go away
but
the argument gets smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller like you don't
see
a full-on public communistic party today
like you saw
back in hollywood behind closed doors
but there's still
a group of people i don't like the the
word comment
you know how the other day i was talking
to the guy and he says you know i'm
running a business i'm doing four or
five million i don't want to say the
guy's name but you know what i'm talking
about he wanted to bring a partner and
to give him equity
to help grow the company and he says but
i don't know how to put it i said you
have to realize you have the business
which means the controls are on who
yeah i said what you're saying is the
word control
is what control and trust go together
right control and trust go together
okay fine so if control and trust go
together lazy
and bored go together okay bitter
and lack of creating go together you
know what word goes together with
communism or socialism what is it
free power and control no it's not free
it's power and control
socialism and communism is to have power
over you and to control you
what is it the government that has power
control over you of course yes
i'm forcing you to pay higher taxes i'm
forcing you
to do what i tell you to do that's
purely force there is no choice in that
the only choice i have is leave the
country it's not choice that's force
you're forcing me out
is what you're doing circling back to
kai with norway
you you kind of said that they're
socialists but they're capitalists what
kind of power and control
does the norwegian government have over
the people with taxes you know that kind
of stuff so i think
a lot of it depends on culture as well
and
and if you're smaller because norway has
a is a culture where it's
a non-confrontational you're more polite
you're
you act responsibly uh and the
government
kind of abides by those rules as well
where they're acting responsibly and
they're not
serving their own interests uh
campaigning in norway is basically
non-existent
there's no political campaigns they
don't they're not even allowed to
advertise
what do you think about that i think
what do you think about that i think you
can't campaign what does that mean
essentially they campaign but the whole
money aspect
is out raise money and and so you're
getting money you know big money i think
that's a great thing
would you like that in america campaign
finance reform i think is yes
okay are you sure you want to say yes am
i instinctually
to have someone like bloomberg come in
and spend 100 million dollars in
florida to have the koch brothers
dominate the republican party
to have sheldon addison rest in peace
you don't speak ill of the dead
dominate the republican party yeah i
think
that was a um i think would that ever
happen in america
would whatever happen where you you
don't you can't raise money to campaign
i think it's uh you can't put the genie
back in the bottle i mean what what was
the
the big was it in 2010 or the campaign
finance reform or what the
what was the way you can't take money
from it how much what's the term what's
the term i'm thinking i i i know what
you're talking about i don't know but
it's basically big donations you know
it's the whole
super pacs everything like that you know
secret dark money do you think both
sides would go away with that
no but getting big money out of politics
i think is a very good thing
not like getting it out of there well i
mean i like you you can buy your own
candidate
and then you know you know what would
happen if that was the case what's
what happens if that's the case where
you can't take money i mean politicians
wouldn't be making as much money there
there's not the same interest to run to
work in politics what else what else
would be a problem if that were to take
place
uh lobbying self-funding yeah so if it's
self-funding then the guys that have the
money would run
so there's also there's a there's a but
it's it's also your
you're well you can you can you can
raise money from people though
but no people i'm saying that's fine but
getting like the george soros's of the
world to just throw in
you know the bloombergs of the world
it's a different story it's a different
story small
25 donations i'm cool with like the
bernie model
i'm cool with whether you agree with
bernie or not he had millions of people
saying dude i'm down with bernie here's
10 bucks
i'm cool with that to have the koch
brothers come in or the soros has come
in saying
here's 100 million good luck like i
don't think you can just buy your way to
the presidency
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye